it's like a little flash that's a look
at the Qatar me babe if I'm really
honest I'll er should come with a
warning babe these lashes what max gram
will need Josh using house and today we
are joined by Jordan we're
now we are going to use your new Euler
collection aren't we
because those lashes are goals babe
you're always eyelash goals I think it's
all about a lash I love to wake up and
have a wash normally I have eyelash
extension so that was kind of my
inspiration for the lashes that I made I
love the names our Beach please la baby
in summer air I feel like coming into LA
moods okay great let's do that this one
is from my collaboration with Kylie
cosmetics it is Kylie and Jordan palette
we're just focusing on the eyes hmm
because eyes are the window to your soul
right babe what would your soul say if
we could peer into your soul I don't
know stay close this is definitely not
your color
I'm gonna like a modern piece of art by
the end of this I've got a feeling you
know there's no such thing as bad art so
you're using the Kylie and Jordan
palette right now babes what was it like
what did you learn about each other from
working on air I just learned how much
she knows about things that I have no
clue about when it comes to makeup like
the percentage of how much it should be
pressed and this and that I don't know
anything about that most people don't
but she's very involved with everything
when it comes to her makeups what do you
think even lying about being a boss
whilst being in the public eye would you
say I think a true boss knows that
there's always more to learn keep going
there and see what works modeling really
helps me find my confidence
and break out of my shell and now I
can't come to London and do your makeup
I mean this was the goal babe wasn't
there at the end of the day what do you
think it's been like your biggest makeup
regret I used to be a tomboy actually
really
I bought foundation but I didn't oh I've
also had this problem well I'm glad
you've rectified that don't be scared
that was touch and go babe my heart was
flat ring so the secret to lashes you
put the glue on you don't have to put
crazy money just put the glue on and I
like to let it sit for a second for the
glue is that kind of tacky fun fact I
always wanted to go to college when I
was 14 because I wanted to be a doctor
oh I like that you'd be such a chic
doctor babe then I realized I didn't
want to go to school for 16 years I'll
let you track my pulse anytime babes I
mean the guy that is life goals isn't
that really that's what I love about
there so like I don't I don't like
anything too heavy on my face you've
also talked a lot about body positivity
as well babe yeah in your career and I
feel like that's such a great message to
send out there to like young girls no
one's perfect
we all have far as benefit some things
that you don't like about yourself just
fix it and if you can't fix it then it's
beautiful then ernet accept it
and that's what makes you you well you
have a really deep crease here just
gonna enhance it a deep crease let's
keep this show PG so if you're into Club
babe
and I've got my lashes on and I see a
cute boy
I cast a bar how am I gonna like style
it out
am I gonna rely on the eyelashes oh that
is one sexy look that's a look that
could turn me babe if I'm really on it
like that was that was a laugh I'll er
should it should come with a warning
babe these lashes it's a base I feel
like this is the ultimate Saturday night
outlet like where we go and what we're
doing what survive okay oh my god I am
achieved a is that perfect are you hot
and spicy honey I think you are medium
oh she's a medium had you down more is a
hot hot hot just tie it all together
nothing too dark
we're here to shine where your birthdays
are no a long time I feel like I need to
see what the results are oh I mean babe
this is look I feel like we've really
bonded over these eyelashes oh I'd be
winking at you babe either coming over
warning it's empowering it's gonna lift
you up just like the woman that sound
boom
[Music]